for people who still don't think that
microaggressions are a problem oh so
well spoken just just imagine instead of
being a stupid comment a microaggression
is a mosquito bite it's a compliment
it's a mosquito bite if you think it's a
mosquito bite mosquito bites and our
itch are one of Nature's most annoying
features
but if you're only bitten every once in
a while no where are you
really from uh Cleveland sure it's
annoying but it's not that big a deal
the problem is that you know what got me
over like caring about bug bites was
when we were with Tom Shea and we went
on a walk in the woods and like it was
the first time I've ever just been going
on a hike and then we just walked
through a river casually when it was
like 40 degrees out he's just like we're
going this way we just like knee-deep in
water I'm like my shoes
and then he was like man shut up and
then um I was asking him I was like so
what happens with like bug bites and
stuff overseas and he's like you just
don't think about it just don't think
about it I was like all right and then I
just like stopped thinking about bug
bites his mind is so strong we trained
to to just ignore inconvenience and
ignore pain big pain and small pain that
that's how that's why seals are G's
that's why they get through life better
than most people yeah but learning that
one lesson no yeah just keep recalling
that mindset I'll have I'll have a bug
bite and I'd be like it's just a bug
bite but then here these people are like
microaggressions are like a bug bite and
it's like it don't it only is a bug bite
if you think it's a bug bite like you're
only letting it bother you because
that's what you think so like the one
you're so well spoken like I've read
that to people you're really well spoken
I really like that about I've said it to
white people I've said it to black
people it doesn't mean that there's a
little thought in my head you know for
your well-spoken for a black person like
what how dare you assume that first of
all that there's there there there's
something hateful or bigoted and also
why why do you want to live your life
looking for
ulterior motives all the time imagine
how sad and depressing it must be to go
through life thinking that everybody
interact with is is is is actually
saying something mean and snarky to you
like that is a really sad way to go
through life yeah that's really
something just take the compliment
thanks I am well spoken hmm that's it
that's it and of course yeah I really
don't see how that could be taken rudely
at all and even if you are black and
you're like if you see it like that it's
like a lot of black people do speak like
a different type of English like I'm
just being honest here like there's
black people for some reason they speak
like black English am I right like
that's not even crazy to say no it is
that's not even crazy white people who
can't [__] who can't put it who can't
put a sentence together either no I know
it's more of a class issue I think than
anything no yeah I would definitely I
would definitely agree but like yeah if
like you know if you come from an area
where there's a lot of people that speak
poorly and then you speak clear and
concisely like and you get complimented
for it how is that an aggression in any
sense that makes no sense at all we
should be encouraging that but you know
what the funny thing too is with with
black people in those neighborhoods what
they do if you do speak more cohesively
like clear and um coherently they um
they like make fun of you for if you
don't talk I know it's really sucks they
call it so it's like yeah they call you
white for speaking more more clearly
which is just like weird and I want to
make it really clear that the reason
we're even making this about black and
white is because they very deliberately
chose a blonde white lady to say you're
so well spoken to The Blacklist I'm not
I feel like I'm being totally reasonable
here like I'm I'm saying stuff that's
like very base knowledge I'm not that
just people won't say but I'm like
whatever but but when you look at Life
Through The Eyes of constantly being
victimized and that's your choice I know
you're not wrong you're gonna be sad and
miserable you don't have to this is an
option this is optional looking at this
this imaginary this video looks at
it look at it is totally optional yeah I
could be an angry angry bitter woman say
that the man held me down yeah like
whatever no he didn't the problem is
that some people get bitten by
mosquitoes a lot more than others
it's just like oh is that look at the
white guy I know over there with no bugs
wait for it wait for it people I mean
why did they fly a bird over to him like
the the constant attack on white people
is so funny
but the thing is like I don't take it
yeah I don't take it personally I'm just
like this this is just it's all funny to
me how you're constantly trying to like
act like we're so much we're up here
with everything and like black people
are so oppressed and they face all this
this victim they're they're victims to
everything basically I would just like
to one one by one peel people off into
the sanity of going back to choosing
people who are in your life and
evaluating People based on the content
of their character not not based on the
color of their skin because the people
who who are so hyper focused on the
color of skin are just they're keeping
themselves Frozen in frustration instead
of moving themselves and their families
forward it's it's just so sad and such a
waste of time and nobody I'm glad that
you said it doesn't bother you but it
bothered me in the beginning and now I'm
just like oh [__] off I don't even care
what you think anymore because you
clearly have no logic and no emotional
intelligence the people that are doing
this but it does bother me like that
Disney video we saw where they're doing
doing it to children and they're taking
children and dividing their minds
against each other yeah it's crazy how
that works that's not cool that's not
cool they've gone too far so when I
remember that now I'm mad you get a
rattle day but oh your English is so
good excuse me one grocery shopping you
know everything happens for a reason I'm
just
muting who walks up to some person in a
in a wheelchair and be like oh
everything happens for a reason like
this is just stupid let's just move on
commuting to work so when are you gonna
have a baby watching TV
is being nosy it's not being aggressive
not even in a micro way yeah none of
these have been aggressive oh my God why
do you assume that I want a baby I'm a
woman I want my career wait listen to
this how dare you that's funny you gotta
have a baby watching TV
I like how they do like the super the
super white male voice we have to keep
the [__] name it's part of our
culture it's like dude no one no one
said that you guys were complaining
about something nobody said that at all
nobody ever said that they just said
they liked it and nobody was mad about
the Redskins game Indians weren't mad
about it it was a bunch of white ladies
that's the thing it's like you guys got
mad over people for you defended people
who didn't care that's what it is when
feminists are screaming about a toxic
masculinity I'm like no no no no you
don't speak for me well it's also just
the ugly bride because the ugly broads
aren't don't get the benefits of toxic
masculinity that's why they complain
about it just walking down the street
ugly on the inside I couldn't even tell
okay mosquitoes seem to pop up
everywhere
too and getting bit by mosquitoes every
goddamn day cut your hair multiple times
a day
oh you are so pretty oh my God that's
terrible when somebody says that I
remember all four compliments I've ever
gone
best moments of my life like like just
just shut up oh God it's so again so sad
to look through life through turd
colored glasses that's what they do
everything is a turd to them everything
these people suck men
so okay where's AOC now so so this woman
is loving these mosquitoes represent
white people white people clearly I mean
blame throwing them into ashes and then
here come white people getting nervous
about the flamethrower really let's
let's keep really okay to people who
only get bit every once in a while no
it's just the mosquito bite who cares
black woman
just another victim mentality victim
yeah another victim another victim
mentality victim yeah yes that's awesome
I mean I couldn't imagine if I thought
every single bad thing that happened to
me was because of like the color of my
skin or something like that I mean my
life I'd be miserable but if you just go
through life recognizing that stuff's
gonna happen regardless it doesn't have
to do with the color of your skin you
just deal with [__] it's just part
of life it's part of your Growing Pains
it it is increasing your bullshitometer
of stuff you could deal with in the
future it's a month it's a much
healthier output it really is and you
know it's funny because I you know you
I'll see some people who have all this
anger uh talk about God too and if you
they were really close with God and
really had a relationship they would
understand God God isn't having any of
this God doesn't worry about this God if
you living by God's laws you wouldn't
you would not even have time to have
these negative thoughts on God and it's
it you know it's just so sad that
they're they're filling entire
communities and entire generations with
hate for no reason and it's doesn't
solve anything in fact it just makes
things worse I do think this will pass I
do think that the country and the world
are getting fed up with all this
[__] and all this hatred and I think
we're gonna come past it and I think 10
years 20 years we're going to look back
and go wow that was some crazy times and
then we'll have some other crazy stuff
to deal with top G for president
some mosquitoes carry truly threatening
diseases that can mess up your life for
years after
if maybe you should try this challenging
major
wow what dreams
um okay so maybe that's not because
there's color your skin maybe you're
just maybe you're just an idiot maybe
you're a c student and and all of a
sudden you want to go to school and
switch into uh you got in on on basket
weaving major and now I'm going to
switch to astrophysics oh my god there
was one oh my god did they have the
accounts at your high schools to the
audience I mean they probably didn't but
like where the the kids would get
together and then they would talk about
all the racist stories and stuff and
there was one that was like at my high
school no no no no I'm talking to the no
some kid was like he said the teacher
was racist because the teacher said um
his guidance counselor said um he should
apply to like Dumber school or like
easier to get into schools too the kid
didn't have good grades and he was like
I want to go to Harvard and um the
teacher's like we should apply for some
less schools too but it's like if you
all like we just talked about this like
if you think every bad thing that
happens to you is because of your this
the color of your skin it's just like
that's the first thought that's gonna go
in your mind it's like believing in
depression and thinking that if
something bad happens in your life or
you don't feel good it's because of your
depression and not because of all the
other things that you're doing wrong
yeah it's the same exact logic just
can't just can't buy into that [__] so
it's the slave mind he does carry
strains that can even kill you you
looked like he was up to trouble okay I
felt are we talking about micro the
progressions or bullets flying what are
we talking about here
oh oh this is another mosquitoes carry
strains that can eat and like why can't
you have some like personal like
accountability here like your college
counselor your career counselor isn't
like the most like the biggest
determining factor of your life like you
are your own person your sovereign
individual you can make your own
decisions a career counselor telling you
should maybe try a less challenging
major regression in a mosquito bite and
I got it now it's gonna hurt me forever
if you decide to then go and do that
less challenging major and and get stuck
in that career that's on you bro that's
on you that's all on you that's not
that's not anything to do with this
little mosquito fella we're partnering
up with a Navy SEAL friend of ours Tom
Shea toast a 21 day virtual event that
you guys can join with us Tom is going
to teach you how to listen to your mind
in a new way and how to control it so
that you can have the discipline you
need to build the life you want so I've
seen this process done for 30 years when
you make it through you will be a
different human being the process is
simple but not easy because of the war
that's inside of us that few people have
been taught to fight overcoming your
excuses so if you're interested in
becoming a reformed human an absolute
animal go to tomshay.com and use Sunny
fast50 for 50 off of this program you
will not regret it you will be a changed
person at the end of it do not miss this
trial is challenging major
and then look at here oh oh stuck in the
nine to five did you see the chain he's
stuck in a nine to five no you don't
have a chain this is America another
choices look he's chained to the desk of
the job he doesn't really this is
propaganda in its finest I mean I
remember when I was thinking like and I
was when I was in high school and I
thought like the college I get into
um you know I thought all of this [__]
was like actual determining factors of
your life because that's what they
convinced you to think I'm sure a lot of
you guys thought the same stuff when you
were in high school like oh my God if I
don't go into this college if I don't
get this a my life is over and it's
crazy when you get out and you're like
wow that actually like didn't mean
anything like not like at all like I
thought like even in high school I was
like I understand this isn't as
important as I think it is right now but
it's definitely still important and now
it's like it just didn't matter in one
like one bit it's crazy and and this
mentality of you're just stuck in a
swarm of mosquitoes and they're all just
gonna suck your blood and hurt you
um there's no there's no thickening of
the skin no man like none I haven't
heard one positive thing here here that
said listen even if you think someone's
insulting you just carry on like I've
been insulted a thousand times in my
life the funny thing is I've been
insulted and I just I either say
something back or I just walk away and
go you know and then carry on but to to
make everything like the world is out to
get me is so unproductive how your
dreams are destroyed because one person
said maybe you shouldn't that that
person's not your problem your problem
is your weak mind yeah you know what's
funny too is like I get more hate for
being white than black people get for
being black I can guarantee it like even
on like I was on an airplane the other
day coming back from Mexico and there's
this girl sitting next to me and um she
goes to you I asked her where do you go
to college whatever she's like I go to
UF I'm like how do you like it she's
like too many white people I'm like what
like what like what does that even like
imagine I said too many too many Spanish
people too many black people like how
how are you so how are you convinced
that you can just say that nowadays I'm
so curious about some context what
nationality he was this girl Mexico I
mean was she white she was Latina oh too
many white people then go to college in
Mexico if there's too many white people
I know but no but I'm like like I heard
that and I was just like all right I'm
just not talking to you anymore I would
have I would have considered you for um
you know a potential date one day maybe
no that would have that would have been
the best move of your life but you know
too bad I cannot believe that somebody
actually felt comfortable to a stranger
on an airplane I felt comfortable enough
to just say that to a stranger on an
airplane and that's not even like
there's there's plenty of stories that
have happened to me just like that I'm
sure everyone can attest as a white
person where it feels like you just get
like [__] on all the time even just
watching this video but um I remember I
was getting too many wait I'm just I'm
just it's just sinking in that somebody
said to you too many white people what
how is that okay if it was the opposite
and you said she said how do you like
living in Florida and you were like yeah
too many too many Mexicans the cops
would have ended up having to come on
the plane she would have found that she
would have been feeling unsafe oh I'd be
on the news you'd be on the news it's
crazy wow just keep going she should be
on the news shame on you if you're
watching
that can even kill you he looked like he
was up to trouble okay I felt threatened
so next time you think someone's
overreacting just remember some people
experience mosquito bites all the time
you're all so exotic wow and by mosquito
bites we mean microaggressions
smash the white people
that was something that was that was
something so if you get even if it's
true and these are microaggressions
right just for the sake of conversation
toughen up be stronger be better but
it's not true they're not
microaggressions all right thank you
guys so much for watching make sure to
like subscribe follow me on Instagram
follow my mom on Twitter
um and join my Discord if you want a
free preview of how I've generated five
million dollars online using organic
marketing and how you can do the same
but you know not everyone can do it
anyone can do it see what I'm saying
that makes sense not everyone can do it
but anyone can do it so I'm teaching you
what I did and you can apply it do it
yourself all right whatever I'll see you
later
there's a big [__] ing [__] cracking
the first shot I'd rather riding on the
wall won't last long yeah the feelings
[Music]